طب صلاح الكود برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو
وحزب العظمه اليهوديه برئاسه عثمان غفير
الى اتفاق ياتلافيا اوليه يمهد الطريق الى
توقيع مزيد من الاتفاقات مع شركاء حكومه
نتانيه المرتبه سيتولى حقيبه الامن القومي
مع صلاحيات واسعه تشمل اداره الشرطه حرس
الحدود في الضفه الغربيه المحتله كما
ستسند الى حزبه وزاره تطوير الجليل والنقب
والمنع الوطني كما سيحصل حزب العظمه
اليهودي على رئاسه لجنه الامن الداخلي
بالكنيسات ونائب وزير الاقتصاد وكان
بالجزيره توصل الى اتفاق المبدئيا حول
الخطوط العريضه للحكومه الجديده تضمنت
تسويه الوضع القانوني ل 65 بؤره للسيطاليه
عشوائيه في الضفه الغربيه
معنا من القدس مراسلنا الياس كرام الياس
كل ما ورد في هذا الاتفاق وتسلم بالكثير
لحقيبه الامن القومي كيف سيكون انعكاس على
الارض وفق القراءه
التطرف في هذه الحكومه او الجناح الاشد
تطرفا في الحكومه اليمنيه الجديده
المرتقبه والتي يسعى بنيامين نتنياهو الى
تشكيلها في قادم الايام لكن من الواضح بان
شخصيه بن جرير سوف تضع على سياسه هذه
الحكومه اتمار بن جري مدان بثماني ملفات
جنائيه من بينها الاخلال بالنظام العام
والتشويش عمل الشرطه في تاديه واجبهم
التحريض على العنفي والعنصريه وكذلك هو
مدان
دعم تنظيما ارهابي وهو بالتالي سيتولى
حقيبه الشرطه الاسرائيليه اي الحقيبه التي
ستكون مسؤوله عن انفاذي القانون والتي
سيطلق عليها من الان فصاعدا همم حقيبه
الامن القومي بدلا من حقيبه الامن الداخلي
سيكون مسؤولا بطبيعه الحال عن اداره
الشرطه الاسرائيليه ومع توسيع لصلاحياته
في اداره شرطه حرس الحدود في ارجاء الضفه
الغربيه المحتله وتمكينه ايضا من توسيع ما
يعرف بالحرس القومي اا في اسرائيل الذي
دعت اوساط يمنيه الى انشائيه في اعقابه
الهبه الجماهيريه للفلسطينيين في داخل
الخط الاخضر فيما يؤمن عام 2021 وان كان
الهدف المعلن من هذا الحرس الوطني هو ااه
توفير السياده الاسرائيليه في ال- ايه في
داخل اسرائيل لكن واضح بان الهدف الرئيسي
همم هو قمع اي هبه جماهيريه اخرى
للفلسطينيين في داخل الخط الاخضر وقنعها
بالحديد والنار بن كبير واضح بانه من
الداعين الى اقتحامات اليهود للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك وتكثيف في هذه الاقتحامات
والسماح لهم حتى باداء الطقوس التلموديه
واداء الصلوات هو من اشد
المدافعين عن ضروره تعزيز الاستيطان
واطفاء الشرعيه القانونيه على بؤرا
الاستيطانيه عشوائيه حتى ان الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه لم تكن تعترف
بوجودها على الارض